presumptive democratic nominee joe biden
is narrowing down his pick for a running
mate with the democratic national
convention just two weeks away
former national security adviser and u.n
ambassador susan rice is apparently
among those being considered
her best-selling memoir tough love my
story of the things worth fighting for
is now available in paperback it's
published by simon
schuster a division of viacom cbs
ambassador rice good morning to you we
are down the straightaway
and i think people want to know have you
been able to interview
with joe biden yet well good morning uh
jerica and good morning everyone uh i
can't talk about uh the process as it
stands
i want to respect the vice president and
his ability
to pick the the person that he deems
best so
i'm not going to get into the details
but i'm honored to be among those
that are reportedly being considered
what argument will you make ambassadors
to why you should be the vice
presidential pick
well there we all each of us it's an
extraordinary group of women
have uh strengths uh that that set us
aside from
the others in my case i think what i
would bring
is almost 20 years of deep experience at
the senior most
ranks of the executive branch getting
things done
for the american people wrestling with
crises
and dealing with the solutions we need
so that's
my background as national security
advisor and many other roles that i've
held
and i think that that's uh very
important given the nature of the crisis
that
a new administration would face from the
pandemic to economic recession
to our global leadership which is uh
suffering enormously
many of these other potential candidates
have all run for office
you have not does that hurt you does
that help you and how
well it's a difference uh some might say
it's a weakness
in my judgment uh i have had the
opportunity to work
at three presidential campaigns i've
campaigned on behalf of others just not
on behalf of myself but
i do think this is going to be quite a
different election given the pandemic
and much of
the interaction unfortunately with the
american people will take place remotely
and your experience as you talk about is
is heavy in foreign policy how do you
relate then to the average person
especially as
you're talking about facing a pandemic
and an economy that's suffering
uh people that aren't working right now
how do you relate to them
well jerica i understand very much what
our country is going through
and in fact as national security advisor
and un ambassador one of my
responsibilities was to deal with global
pandemics
we dealt with the ebola epidemic we
dealt with the zika virus we dealt with
the h1n1 flu
pandemic frankly much more effectively
than unfortunately we've seen of late
so i understand what disease can do i
understand
deeply the economic repercussions for
americans who are suffering enormously
and how that suffering has
disproportionately affected
communities of color in this country
particularly african americans and
latinos
so we have enormous amount of work to do
to come together
to tackle these challenges far more
effectively and with a collective sense
of purpose than
what we have seen under donald trump's
leadership historically vice
presidential candidates are sort of in
the background and
out rallying and championing for the
presidential uh
the person that they're teamed up with
to potentially become the next president
what do you think is the most important
attribute and are you prepared to sort
of play that role
in just supporting biden
well of course the the running mate
whoever she may be
uh first and foremost has to be uh
acting in support of the candidate
uh and governing as a partner uh should
he win
uh so i absolutely think that's the
vitally important role it's not about
one's own profile i certainly haven't
run for president i haven't run for
other office so
in my case uh i don't have a personal uh
political ambition i have a
long-standing commitment to public
service uh
that's been what's defined my career and
whether i'm
privileged to serve in with the vice
presidency or in any other capacity
i just want to give my utmost to this
country into
the very critical importance of helping
joe biden
uh put in place of policies that will
benefit the american people at a time
when we're suffering so much
in the new afterward in your book you
write about the recent protests sparked
by as you quote the long
suppressed agony of african-american
communities
over never ending police brutality
do you support the call to defund police
jericho no that's not terminology that i
would use
but what i would say is this we have a
long history of
inequality of oppression that endures in
this country
and we need the police to be part of the
solution
in some instances they are in other
communities they're not there's no
one-size-fits-all approach so i'm for
reimagining the role of the police
getting them out of
things like social work i'm for
responsible
reallocation of resources where that
makes sense to invest more in our
communities
and the health of our citizens but it
doesn't
fit a one-size-fits-all approach you
can't just
take money away uniformly and put it
somewhere else or take it away
altogether i think
we need to look at this community by
community and be quite
thoughtful about it the book is called
tough love there's no secret that
you have no problem giving tough talk at
times
but you say that this is a point in
america where we are facing a
tough love moment what did you mean by
that
well tough love to me means loving
fiercely
but not uncritically it's how my parents
raised me it's how i've tried to
raise my children that means you tell
the tough truths that
someone you love needs to hear and here
we are in america at a moment where
we've been knocked down by a pandemic by
recession by
divisive and competent leadership and by
our failure to reckon with racial and
socioeconomic injustice
we've got to get back up we can i
believe deeply in this country
and our ability when we have unity and
resolve and collective purpose
to accomplish anything so this is a
moment where we need to understand what
we're facing
come together and defeat it day one
let's just say we have uh president
biden
what do you think should be the first
issue that he's looking at when it comes
to foreign policy
well jericho there are many many aspects
that he's going to have to look at
unfortunately
the challenges are are many but i think
the most important thing is to restore
and re-establish
and renew our relationships with our
allies and partners which have suffered
so much
we have a president who's embraced our
adversaries from putin to kim jong-un
and disparaged our our traditional
allies from germany to canada
to south korea our strength in the world
our ability to lead and get things
done depends on our allies and partners
wanting to join with us
we need to repair those relationships
and we need to restore trust
an ambassador if you're not picked what
will be your role
i will do anything i can uh jerica this
is not about me
this is about uh our country and uh
restoring new leadership and i will
raise money i will do the the 21st
century equivalent of licking envelopes
i'll serve in whatever capacity that
vice president biden thinks i can best
serve and i will support
uh wholeheartedly whoever he chooses to
be his vice presidential running mate
this is a critical moment in our history
and i think the most important
election of our lifetimes and i look
forward to doing everything i can to
help him win
help us win the senate and then to help
president biden govern effectively
ambassador susan rice we thank you for
your time the paperback edition
of tough love is now on sale